in the lobby of financial peace Plaza
George and Nicole are with us hey guys
how are you hey great Dave how are you
better than I deserve welcome welcome
where do y'all live just north of
Houston fun fun so you're in Nashville
on the eve of Thanksgiving to do a debt
free scream we are yeah very cool well
good welcome welcome so uh what are the
kiddos names and ages this is Lauren
she's 12 mhm this is Addie she turns 11
tomorrow William is seven and Sophie is
six of course she is that's perfect I
love it so how much debt have you guys
paid off we have paid off a little over
1.2 million ho ho there's always that
okay yeah I didn't see that one coming
all right so uh how long did this take
20 months okay and there's got to be a
story here and household income is what
uh it's about 175 okay so we know you
didn't cash flow that right you sold
what everything yeah everything we sold
uh houses businesses cars you name it we
sold it we downsized twice in the last
18 months um wow sold got rid of luxury
cars we're driving Fords and Chevys we
now you are yeah yeah yeah okay what
where are you driving uh Audi and
infinity okay all right and so we moved
down and car tens of thousands of
dollarss all right and and how much
house we had two houses we had uh uh one
house that was a little over a million
dollars and we had a vacation home that
was a little over a million dollar that
we sold both of those that we owed money
on both of those okay all right and so
that cleared off a lot of this debt it
did I'm guessing how much of the 1.2
million were those two mortgages uh
total was about 800
850 Okay so we've still got 350 here and
you said you sold a business we did we
had uh we had two different businesses
that we sold luckily the the houses we
weren't upside down in either of them so
we were able to take the money from
those and and pay off the business debt
as well as the businesses were uh we
profited from those as well so what do
you do now um we started another
business we're pay paying for that in
cash and we're building a new house that
we're paying for in cash that we move in
in three weeks wow so phenomenal what a
shift well I think that's our story is
that we just got sucked into this
cultural norm of bigger is better and
more and debt and debt and so what what
flipped the switch Financial Peace
University no way really yeah we got a
dog and a little a little boy dog and
between our little boy dog and you the
kids know that y'all are both my
boyfriends so we call our dog my
boyfriend and we call you my boyfriend
and
so that's funny I love it well I'm right
up there with the dog that's good so
that's perfect what kind of what kind of
dog is this a little mini snower oh
perfect there you go got the right beard
and everything that's good okay good
that's my buddy all
right don't tell me his name's Ramsey
okay just don't tell me that that was
kicked around though
literally okay so uh I'm dying you're
quite entrepreneurial this is excellent
what kind of business are you opening
this time there it's a franchise called
Orange Theory Fitness U we've been in
the franchise world for 10 years now um
and so this is just a New Concept that
we've started and it's under
construction right now wow so it's a a
fitness uh like a gym yes it's a fitness
studio group group training okay Group
Training great good for you phenomenal
obviously have a knack for it and have
done really well so you just wandered
into Financial Peace University and had
no idea everything's getting ready to
get turned upside down um we she had
more of an idea than I did okay all
right well you got
tricked but it was uh it was through our
church and we we had Nicole had read
some of the books and I read a couple of
your books and and it was just it was
time to do it it we had realized that it
was okay so it wasn't like that sudden
in since you were you're starting to
build this up but then sitting down the
class was the culmination the process
yeah the process that that actually
showed us exactly what to do step by
step and that's we couldn't have done it
without that that's that's what got us
there so you guys went radical I mean
when I say sell so much stuff the kids
think they're next you had a couple I
mean William was hiding buddy I'm
telling you he's like uh hiding behind
his mom over here no don't tell me so uh
uh you you did get really radical you
had to have some friends and family look
at you and go have y'all lost it oh yeah
no no doubt about that but we were
talking about it yesterday that when you
talk about the stuff that we gave up and
sell it sounds like it's a really big
deal and it and and looking back it it
was meaningless the stuff that we that
we placed our our Treasures our our
worth on were just it was just stuff and
and now that we've sold it and gotten
rid of it it's we feel we're we're free
we're was it was it painful while you
were doing it emot painful it was oh my
gosh it was beans and rice sometimes I
mean here we were making $250,000 and I
was like okay we got $7 to get us
through dinner tonight and you know
we're going to go see what we can get at
the grocery store for that so I mean
there were some hard certainly some hard
steps cuz we took the plan and we
followed the plan um but you did so much
dramatic change in your life with extra
houses and house going and moving down
in cars was that emotionally painful or
were you just so disgusted by the time
you got ready to sell the thing things
that you didn't feel it it was more like
good riddens kind of a little bit of
both yeah I think a little bit of both
okay yeah I mean we were ready for it um
it was it was just the right time to do
it it doesn't make it any easier but um
it was once we did it it felt really
good yeah I I remember the first time or
two we did something along those lines
it was really hard but then when we
figured out it didn't didn't really
matter it was like the next time we're
like ah just get rid of it right and cuz
you know it's like we're getting rid of
a boat one time and I was going I'll get
another one yeah you know and this time
I'll get it I'll own it it won't own me
exactly exactly he sees Audi go by and
he's like oo soon I'm going to pay for
one in
cash there you go and there's some nice
Audi out there right now A Audi's
building a good car right now they are
that's fun well congratulations you guys
you ought to be very proud of yourselves
so did you guys fight at all oh
never was that the sarcasm font yeah
that
was that was it so you weren you weren't
fighting during this process or or
before the process uh no through the
process we had our we had our moments um
but I I have to give Nicole all the
credit that she kept us on path and and
it was uh it I fought it a lot and um
now that we're through the process I I
couldn't I couldn't thank her more okay
yeah CU you are in a position with your
ability to earn an income uh and no debt
you guys are free you can you're going
to be able to live and give like no one
else you really are it's a pretty cool
thing you've been through well this is
dramatic I mean it is so dramatic you
sold everything we did yeah you really
sold everything and I mean because
that's a that's 1.2 million in 20 months
that may I mean it's not the most
anybody's ever paid off but it may be
the fastest yeah yeah well you know it's
kind of surreal being here cuz I feel
like when we sat through the very first
class of FPU and like you look at these
baby steps and I remember we went home
that night and baby step one was put
$1,000 in the bank for you know the um
emergency fund starter emergency fund 20
months ago it was so long ago I forget
what it was even called but like I
thought okay yes Step One is done and
then step two was pay off debt and it
was like whoa that's huge and then I
realized okay we don't have the patience
to like make a plan for that long like
what do we need to do today to make this
happen today and so I think that's where
we got on the the sell stuff we're
living in this massive house do we need
this massive house you know do we need a
mortgage that's just strapping us down
so MH yeah it it comes at a cost it sure
sure but it looks so just like a
mountain that is couldn't even you
couldn't even begin to walk up until you
just start putting one foot in front of
the other and still you you know you
just put your head down you just get to
the plan so there's no question at the
end of all of this stress and massive
change and moving and selling off
everything in sight it was worth it oh
my gosh so worth it it's it's worth it
for this for being able to have four
children that can live a debt-free
lifestyle and and and understand that
that that what we're doing can be
attainable in a cultural norm doesn't
have to be debt coming out of your ears
to to live this American Dream lifestyle
buying stuff you can't afford money you
don't have impress people you don't
really like right I love it you guys are
incredible what a wonderful family you
guys are amaz all right count it down
let's hear a great debt-free scream
George Nicole Lauren Addison Williams
Sophie count it down let's hear it 3 2 1
we
dead I love it I love it congratulations
you guys man that's serious fun
wow wow 1.2 million
wow this is the Dave Ramsey
[Music]
Show
n